die oligarchen diese oftmals glamouröse
geldadel putins erlebt in den metropolen
der welt scheinbar unbehelligt im luxus
durch die sanktionen des westens soll
gerade auch druck auf diese geld elite
ausgeübt werden damit die wiederum druck
auf putin ausübt und es scheint so
wirkte jedenfalls was die oligarchen
angeht new york der big apple in
verschiedene luxusimmobilien parken
putins getreue milliardäre hier ihr
kapital und jetzt ist bewegung in diesen
großen markt dort auf den
immobiliensektor gekommen 61 luxus
appartements wurden verkauft oder der
preis wurde reduziert zusammen sind es
vermögenswerte von einer milliarde
dollar und wir schalten direkt nach new
york zu unserem korrespondenten herbert
bauernebel herbert also jetzt trifft es
auch die oligarchen in new york
ja so ist es wir haben uns gestern dann
ich habe mich gestern ein bisschen
umgesehen ein bisschen eine art ur
gemacht zu diesen ganzen immobilien von
einigen dieser oligarchen die hier ihr
geld geparkt haben interessant hier in
new york ist dass sie weniger aktiv sind
in der szene als etwa in anderen
oligarchen hochburgen wie in london das
heißt es scheint hier so dass sie mehr
oder weniger das geld hier parken dass
sie das geld hier investieren im big
apple einige sind natürlich involviert
in verschiedene kunst szenerien und
ausstellungen hier in new york aber sie
leben hier unauffälliger als in anderen
metropolen wie in london ein einer
dieser domain hat mir erzählt dass der
besitzer alex alexy kurz mit 8,8
milliarden dollar wert laut forbes in
seiner luxus apartment an der upper east
side dass er in den letzten drei jahren
nur einmal gesehen hat das zeigt
deutlich dass hier diese oligarchen er
im eher versteckt versteckter leben als
als anderswo
arbeit gestern gab es das wichtige
gespräch zwischen
joe biden im amerikanischen präsidenten
und dem chinesischen präsidenten jiang
wir haben gestern kurz darüber
gesprochen jetzt mit etwas abstand wie
ich dieses gespräch einzuordnen was ist
dabei herausgekommen
zwei stunden lang haben sich die
präsidenten amerikas und chinas
unterhalten es ging natürlich
hauptsächlich oder großteils um den
krieg in der ukraine und hier hat us
präsident joe biden seine haltung
neuerlich deutlich gemacht dass er
erwartet dass china das peek gegen
russland hier besonders militärisch aber
auch wirtschaftlich nicht unter die arme
greifen soll das war der
hauptstoßrichtung des amerikanischen
präsidenten
die chinesen haben sich danach zu wort
gemeldet in dem sie gesagt haben
festgestellt haben dass sie nicht
glücklich sind mit diesem krieg in der
ukraine ein echter durchbruch war nicht
zu erwarten bei diesen gesprächen aber
es ist nicht wahr wichtig von
amerikanischer seite eine klare warnung
auszusprechen
das eben peking sich fernhalten soll von
wladimir putin dass sie versuchen sollen
hier nicht indirekt einzugreifen mit
militär und wirtschaftshilfe